is there a border we will never cross
are there places we will never reach no
matter how hard we try
turns out there are
even with science fiction technology we
are trapped in our pockets of the
universe
how can that be
and how far can we go
[Music]
we live in a quiet arm of the milky way
a spiral galaxy of average size about
100 000 light years across consisting of
billions of stars gas clouds dark matter
black holes neutron stars and planets
with a supermassive black hole in the
galactic center
from afar our galaxy seems dense but in
reality it consists mostly of empty
space
with our current technology sending a
human to the closest star would take
thousands of years
so our galaxy is pretty big
the milky way is not alone though
along with the andromeda galaxy and more
than 50 dwarf galaxies it's part of the
local group a region of space about 10
million light years in diameter it is
one of hundreds of galaxy groups in the
laniakea supercluster
which itself is only one of millions of
superclusters that make up the
observable universe
now let's assume for a moment that we
have a glorious future humanity becomes
a type 3 civilization does not get wiped
out by aliens and develops interstellar
travel
based on our current understanding of
physics
in this best case scenario how far could
we possibly go
well
the local group
it is the biggest structure that
humanity will ever be a part of
while it is certainly huge the local
group accounts for only
0.0000001 percent of the observable
universe
let this number sink in for a moment
we are limited to a hundred billionth of
a percent of the observable universe
the simple fact that there is actually a
limit for us and that there is so much
universe that we will never be able to
touch is kind of frightening
why can't we go further
well it all has to do with the nature of
nothing
nothing or empty space isn't empty but
has energy intrinsic to itself so-called
quantum fluctuations
on the smallest scale there is constant
action particles and anti-particles
appearing and annihilating themselves
you can imagine this quantum vacuum as a
bubbling pot with denser and less dense
regions
now let's go back 13.8 billion years
when the fabric of space consisted of
nothing at all
right after the big bang in an event
known as cosmic inflation the observable
universe expanded from the size of a
marble to trillions of kilometers in
fractions of a second
this sudden stretching of the universe
was so fast and extreme that all those
quantum fluctuations were stretched as
well and subatomic distances became
galactic distances
with dense and less dense regions
after inflation gravity began to pull
everything back together
at the largest scale the expansion was
too quick and powerful to overcome but
at smaller scales gravity emerged
victorious
so over time the denser regions or
pockets of the universe grew into groups
of galaxies like the one we live in
today
only stuff inside our pocket the local
group is bound to us gravitationally
but wait
what's the problem then why can't we
travel from our pocket to the next one
here dark energy makes everything
complicated
about six billion years ago dark energy
took over it's basically an invisible
force or effect that causes and speeds
up the expansion of the universe
we don't know why or what dark energy is
but we could observe its effect clearly
in the early universe there were larger
cold spots around the local group that
grew into large clusters with thousands
of galaxies
we are surrounded by a lot of stuff
but none of those structures and
galaxies outside of the local group are
gravitationally bound to us
so the more the universe expands the
larger the distance between us and other
gravitational pockets becomes
over time dark energy will push the rest
of the universe away from us causing all
the other clusters galaxies and groups
to eventually become unreachable
the next galaxy group is already
millions of light years away but all of
them are moving away from us at speeds
we can't ever hope to match
we could leave the local group and fly
through intergalactic space into the
darkness but we would never arrive
anywhere
while we will become more and more
stranded the local group will become
more tightly bound and merge together to
form one giant elliptical galaxy with
the unoriginal name
milk dromeda in a few billion years
but it becomes even more depressing at
some point the galaxies outside the
local group will be so far away that
they will be too faint to detect and the
few photons that do make it to us will
be shifted to such long wavelengths that
they'll be undetectable
once this happens no information outside
of the local group will be able to reach
us the universe will recede from view it
will appear to be dark and empty in all
directions
forever
are being bored in the far future in
milk dromeda will think there is nothing
but its own galaxy in the entire
universe
when they look far into empty space they
will only see more emptiness and
darkness
they won't be able to see cosmic
background radiation and they won't be
able to learn about the big bang
they will have no way of knowing what we
know today the nature of the expanding
universe when it began and how it will
end
they will think the universe is static
and eternal
milk dromeda will be an island in the
darkness slowly getting darker and
darker
still with its trillion stars the local
group is certainly large enough for
humanity after all we still haven't
figured out how to leave our solar
system and we have billions of years to
explore our galaxy
we have the incredible luck to exist at
the perfect moment in time to see not
only our future but also our most
distant past as isolated and remote as
the local group is
we can perceive the entire universe
grand and spectacular as it is right now
thanks so much for the help with the
video to ethan siegel check out his
astronomy blog here
you can support us directly at patreon
or get courtscast merch here it really
helps
it's awesome that you watch this far so
we've made a playlist for you about more
universe stuff